[Music]
although stars appear as simple points
of light in the sky astronomers now know
that almost all of them are orbited by
planets even without being able to see
them researchers have discovered whole
planetary systems and have measured the
sizes masses and orbits of the planets
some tantalizingly similar to earth but
do any of them harbour life answering
that question seems impossible since the
planets are too far and too faint to see
astronomers may soon find an answer by
exploiting the power of spectroscopy
spreading out the various wavelengths of
light prismatic ly to see which ones are
brightest and which might have been
absorbed by something on their way here
when a planet passes in front of its
star some of the Starlight arriving to
telescopes will have passed through the
planet's atmosphere and gases will have
absorbed certain wavelengths space
telescopes such as Hubble are using this
method to detect gases around exoplanets
for now they've only managed this with a
few guest giants not around anything
like earth to find more constituents of
exoplanet atmospheres astronomers need
to block out the light from the star so
that they can see the dim planets and
gather their light directly that can be
done with a mask inside the telescope
called a coronagraph
but far more effective will be a star
shade this is a free-flying spacecraft
which can unfurl a parasol
tens of metres across when stationed
tens of thousands of kilometres away
from a space telescope it can block the
light from a star while leaving planets
in view astronomers hope such space
missions will happen in the next decade
but once we can see exoplanets directly
what signs should we look for to tell us
that life is present what are the bio
signatures if we take earth life as a
guide then looking for the byproducts of
biological processes such as oxygen and
methane seems like a good approach
these gases would normally react and
turn into something else so if they are
detected in large quantities it is a
sign that something such as life is
replenishing them but it's easy to be
fooled methane can be produced by
volcanoes oxygen by ultraviolet light
splitting water similarly it's possible
for life to thrive without producing
such gases as microbes did on the
primitive earth for billions of years
some scientists argue that we shouldn't
be looking out for a duplicate of
earth-based life but should consider all
volatile compounds as possible bio
signatures any atmosphere that is out of
balance with constant replenishment of
reactive gases could be flagging up in
Alien biology astronomers now realize
that detecting atmospheric gases is
unlikely to be enough to convincingly
detect life they will need a holistic
view of a planet
what sort of light rains down from its
star does it have volcanoes how fast
does it rotate the light reflected from
its surface could show a pattern of
absorption like that from our green
photosynthetic plants with the help of
star shades and giant space telescopes
one day we'll get images of such a
distant world they may be only a few
pixels across but researchers have
simulated them using degraded images of
Earth and believe they will be able to
detect oceans and continents rotation
rate and seasons from these they can get
a better idea of a planet's climate and
suitability for life take a close look a
picture like this may be our first
glimpse of a world with life that has
evolved separately from our own
[Music]
you